So on to Sigmund Freud,
we're going to give him somewhat short
shrift,
I'm afraid because we only have an hour
to talk about Freud,
but that's okay.
We could get a fair way through it.
Um,
he's still persona non grata,
I would say among experimental
psychologists and probably clinical
psychologists as well.
But that seems to me to be very unfair.
Um,
Freud,
Freud is one of those thinkers who,
uh,
all that's left are his mistakes.
And the reason for that is that
everything that he discovered or put
forward,
it's so entrenched in our culture now
that we think it's self evident.
And so everything correct has been
assimilated and that just leaves
everything that's more or less floating
on top to look wrong.
And,
but Freud is also one of those thinkers
who was always wrong in an interesting
way and that's very useful.
And so,
um,
I also think that many of the things
that he put his finger on,
that our abs of steel disputed,
for example,
the idea of the oedipus complex are much
more useful than people are willing to
admit,
especially in the clinical realm.
Because the oedipal complex,
which we'll talk about quite a bit,
is actually a,
uh,
a description of a fairly stable form of
familial psychopathology where child
gets trapped within the confines of a
family because the relationship with one
parent or the other or both is so tight
that they can't break beyond it.
And maybe because of their own inability
to move towards independence,
but more frequently because of,
uh,
what you might describe as a kind of
conspiracy between the sun and the
parent or the child and the parent that
prevents them from moving towards
autonomous life and keeps them in a
state of,
essentially a state of childhood
dependence.
Freud said,
I started my professional activity as a
neurologist trying to bring the relief
to my neurotic patients under the
influence of an older friend.
And by my own efforts I discovered some
important new facts about the
unconscious and psychic life,
the role of instinctual urges and so on.
Out of these findings grew a new science
psychoanalysis,
a part of psychology,
and a new treatment for the neuroses.
I had to pay heavily for this bit of
good luck.
People did not believe in my facts and
thought my theories unsavory.
Resistance was strong and unrelenting.
In the end,
I succeeded in inquiring pupils and
building it up in new international
psychoanalytic association,
but the struggle is not over.
He made that recording just shortly
before he died.
He moved to La,
to England to escape the Nazis.
Before Freud,
I guess
the mind was,
it's complicated because Freud of course
was not the only person to be thinking
along the lines that he thought.
Pierre Jenay,
who was one of his teachers had
originated and started to develop.
Many of the ideas that I would say were
popularized by Freud,
but
the idea of the unconscious mind was not
certainly not as well developed prior to
Freud as it became afterwards.
And
before that.
I suppose
you might say that in so far as people
thought of the mind at all they thought
of in philosophical terms and the mind
would be that part of you that's that
you're aware of like in the dark and the
Cartesian sense.
Descartes said,
I think therefore I am and it kind of
seems in some sense self evident that
you're aware of and have control over
the contents of your own mind.
But that was what Freud really
questioned and he questioned it,
deeply said,
well first of all the idea that you're
one thing like one mind is a dubious
idea to begin with because people are
full of internal contradictions and then
the idea that your mind is all of one
type,
it's,
it's all of one form was also very
questionable as far as Freud was
concerned because you could be
fractionated into subcomponents and you
know the idea for example,
that your anger or your sexual desire
could be an autonomous part of your
personality in some sense that it could
overtake you and control you.
That's really afraid and idea.
And one of the classic Freud and ideas
really is that people are made out of
sub personalities and those sub
personalities are alive.
And that's one of the things I really
like about the psychoanalytic thinkers
because even the psychologist who say
over the last 30 years or thereabouts
since maybe longer now anyways,
since the demise of behaviorism as an
ideology
and the admission by psychologists that
there were,
there is an act of unconscious or many
active unconscious,
which is a better way of thinking about
it.
Psychologists still really haven't come
to terms with the idea in any deep sense
that these unconscious processes are
living things.
You know there when when psychologists
talk for example about the cognitive
unconscious,
they're talking about something that
they describe it more machine like with
more machine like metaphors and that's
not reasonable.
You,
you understand things a lot better if
you understand that the sub components
that make up people,
the fragmentary bits of them and also
the biological subsystems that that are
part and parcel of your being are much
more intelligently viewed as
personalities there.
They're kind of unit dimensional
personalities in some sense.
So that for example,
if you're angry,
you're nothing but angry,
I mean that's an overstatement
obviously.
Or if you're afraid you're nothing but
afraid or if you're hungry,
you're nothing but hunger.
While certainly true.
If you get hungry enough or thirsty or
too hot or any of those things,
you,
you kind of collapsed to a simpler
personality that only has one motivation
in mind,
and we'll talk a lot as we progress
about the grounding of those unit
dimensional motivational systems in
biology.
But I'd have to say that Freud was among
the first red least the first to
synthesize a coherent theory of this
multiplicity and to put it forth while
also insisting that much of what was
happening to you and inside of you was
not immediately accessible to your
awareness.
And it's a very profound,
it's very profound discovery.
It means among any among many other
things that you can formulate ideas.
First of all,
it means that you can act out things
that you don't understand for reasons
that you don't understand.
It also means that your memory can
contain things that's represented in one
way,
but that can't be understood it in
another.
So for example,
and we know this is true because there
are independent memory systems,
there's an independent memory system for
procedures.
That's for actions.
There's an independence memory system
for what you might describe as
imagination for,
for the memory that uses images.
And then there's uh,
another system that articulates
knowledge.
That's the semantic memory system.
And it's not obvious at all that the
contents of all of those are equivalent.
And that's why,
for example,
you can dream things that you don't
know.
Cause one of the things you might think
is that your dreams watch you act and
they watch other people act and then
they make a little drama out of that.
And that drama has information in it.
But you don't necessarily know what that
information is in that.
You can't describe it consciously.
Right.
It's,
it's akin to the Ph.
Eddie an idea that kids can play a game
and you can take them away from the game
and then they won't know how to describe
the rules even though they could play
the game.
And so dreams can contain information
that's full of the encoding of behavior
that has information in it that you're
not consciously aware of.
And so then you can become consciously
aware of that in kind of a revelation.
Sayed,
maybe that's what you do when you become
aware of the meaning of a dream or the
meaning of a fantasy or something like
that.
And that's all our ability to think that
way in some ways can be traced back to
Freud.
Now,
Freud concentrated mostly I would say at
least in terms of pathology on sexual
and aggressive impulses and I,
I don't think that there's any mystery
for modern people about why aggressive
impulses might be particularly difficult
to integrate into the personality and
might remain underdeveloped or we'll say
repressed,
although those aren't the same thing.
And I think in order to,
you might think that in different times
in society,
some things are allowed to surface and
express themselves.
And other things are less allowed.
And so Victorian Times had a number of
characteristics that made the repression
of sexuality particularly likely,
and perhaps also the repression of
aggression.
And we're talking about Victorian times
and in Europe obviously,
and only one time in one place
as Henry or Ellenberger,
Jay says,
this is a great book,
by the way,
the discovery of the unconscious.
If you're interested in,
if you're really interested in
psychoanalytic ideas,
Freud,
young and Adler,
and also the history of those ideas,
there's no better book than the
discovery of the unconscious.
It's an absolutely remarkable book,
a great work of scholarship.
I think it,
it goes for about 250 pages before it
even gets to Freud.
And so it places Freud's discoveries in
their historical context.
So that's a really good thing to know.
Allan Burke.
Jay says it was a world shaped by man
format in which women occupied the
second place.
Political Rights for women did not
exist.
The separation and dissimilarity of the
sexist was sharper than today.
Women who wore slacks,
their hair shorter smoke,
we're hardly to be found.
And the university's admitted no female
students.
Man's authority over his children and
his wife was unquestioned education was
authoritarian.
The desk product father was a common
figure and was particularly conspicuous
only when he became extremely cruel.
Laws were more repressive,
delinquent youth,
sternly punished and corporal punishment
was considered indispensable.
Now,
so the times themselves,
I would say were harsher and more
repressive,
but then there was an element to
sexuality that was also
extraordinarily problematic.
I mean,
the first thing you might notice might
consider,
and people generally don't,
it's almost impossible to overstate how
revolutionary the birth control pill
actually is.
You know,
people like to think that the political
rights that women have attained have
been a consequence of a political
struggle,
but I don't buy that for a second.
I don't think that's true even in the
least.
I think that what happened was that we
underwent a biological revolution in the
1950s late 1950s with the emergence of
the birth control pill and that for the
first time in human history gave women
pretty reliable control over their
reproductive function.
Not really transformed them into
entirely different biological beings.
In many,
many ways.
Like here's an example,
a subtle example.
So you know,
if you track women through their
oscillation cycle and you show them a
picture of a man,
same mat and you do nothing but vary his
jaw width when there are relating the
guy with the wider jaws more attractive
and when they're not ovulating,
the farthest away from that,
the guy with the thinner jaws more
attractive and that's associated with
testosterone levels.
And so women who are fertile like more
masculine men.
And basically if you're on the pill,
then you're never in that operation
phase.
And so one thing that may have happened,
and I don't know this for sure,
but it's,
it's interesting to consider,
is that since women have been taking the
birth control pill,
their preference for less masculine men
has become more pronounced.
And that could easily be of the things
that's fueling at least some of the
tension that's existed and exists now
politically between men and women.
But the point is is that you just cannot
ignore the massive consequences of a
biological revolution like that.
And to make any other factor causal.
When you're trying to understand the
political movement movements,
especially in the last say 40 years,
it's you're putting the cart before the
horse.
Now it's reasonable to point out that
the pill wouldn't have been accepted as
a technology if certain political
changes with regards to the emancipation
of women hadn't already been in place,
right?
No one would have even been allowed to
do something like investigate
contraception.
So you can't separate the biological
from the political entirely,
but it's still,
it's still very useful to organize your
organizing,
your thinking,
to realize just how profound a
revolution that was.
But now back in the Victorian Times,
see there's another thing about
sexuality.
Modern people like to think that there's
nothing dangerous about sex and that is
like the stupidest thing you could
possibly ever hypothesize because
everything about it is dangerous.
It's dangerous emotionally,
it's dangerous.
Socially it's dangerous because of the
possibility of unwanted pregnancy.
And it's dangerous because of the
possibility of sickness.
And that's a major one.
I mean,
so when aids emerged in the 1980s that
could have easily killed all of us.
Now the fact that it didn't was
wonderful,
but it did kill hundreds of millions of
people.
So it was no joke.
It was a big deal.
And AIDS mutated to take advantage of
promiscuity.
And so the relationship between sexual
behavior in the transmission of disease
is actually mediated at the biological
level.
But anyways,
back in the 1890s they had the same
problem,
right?
They had the problem with syphilis and
syphilis is one nasty disease.
It's,
it can mimic almost any other disease
and it's devastating to your nervous
system and you can pass it on to your
children.
And so part of the reason that sexuality
was heavily repressed in the Victorian
period was not only because of the
possibility of unwanted pregnancy,
the relative poverty of people,
you know,
back in 1895 in,
in Europe,
the average person lived on less than a
dollar a day.
In modern terms,
you know,
it's almost impossible to understand how
poor people were.
And so sex in a poverty stricken place
is also a lot more dangerous than it is
in a rich place.
Because especially if you were given the
lack of employment opportunities for
women back in the Victorian period,
if you happen to get pregnant out of
wedlock,
you were and you are in serious trouble.
And so the fact that sexuality was
repressed is hardly,
it's hardly a surprise because it was so
difficult to integrate into the full
fledged personality,
you know,
and it as it as it still is.
So sexual repression,
supposedly characteristic feature of the
Victorian period was often merely the
expression of two facts,
the lack of diffusion of contraceptives
and the fear of venereal disease.
It was all the more dangerous because of
the great spread of prostitution and
because prostitutes were almost
invariably contaminated and therefore
potential sources of infection.
We can hardly imagine today how monster
selfoss syphilis appeared to people of
that time.
While we can imagine a little bit better
than they could in 1970 because it
hasn't,
you know,
AIDS is still with us,
although it's nowhere near the plague
that it was say 25 years ago.
Well,
here's the floridian world,
Freud.
So let's,
let's take a look at the history of,
or the idea of the unconscious to begin
with.
And one of the things that you might
want to consider conceptually is that
there are many different forms of
unconscious.
There's not just one.
And so Alan Borchez points out that by
1,904 functions of the unconscious had
been described,
there's a conservative function.
So the unconscious stores memories often
unaccessible to voluntary recall.
Well that's a strange one.
You know,
obviously you remember your past,
but you don't remember all of what you
can remember at any given time.
And you don't really have access to that
full store of memories,
although you can try to remember.
So the unconscious is the,
you could imagine the memories are
represented somehow neurologically,
but neuro,
the neurological structure isn't exactly
the mind.
Like the neurological structure isn't
exactly your consciousness.
There's some relationship between them
that we don't know.
And the unconscious from a conceptual
perspective is the place that your
memories are that you sometimes can get
access to and sometimes can't.
And so you might think,
well that there are the memories that
you can't get access to.
There might be a variety of reasons you
can't get access to them.
One might be that you've just forgotten
and one might be that they're so painful
that you don't want to bring them to
mind.
You'll you'll engage in tricks to stop
yourself from getting access to them and
or maybe they're memories that are so
complex that and painful that even if
you did get access to them,
you wouldn't exactly know what to do
with them.
And so there's not a lot of reason for
you to bring them to mind because all it
is is pain without any,
without any utility.
And when you understand that a little
bit,
you understand more about what Freud
meant by repression.
The think about Freud is that he kind of
believed that like many people believe
now that when you remember an event in
the past,
it's,
it's almost as if you're using a video
tape recorder and that when you
experience that the memory is somehow
recorded in you like it happened.
But that's not a very accurate version
of how memory works.
I mean,
we know that memories can be easily
distorted.
For example,
if you interview some one about an event
and you make suggestions that there was
something present in the event that
wasn't there,
and then you bring them back a couple of
weeks later and you ask them about the
same event,
they'll often incorporate the thing that
they were told into the event.
And so,
and the idea that you can make an
objective record of something that's
happening to you is kind of a strange
notion anyways because,
so for example,
if you're having an argument with
someone and later you're asked what the
argument was about and the other person
is asked what the argument is about,
there's no necessary reason why the
accounts will jibe at all.
Because a lot of time when you're having
an argument with someone,
you're arguing about what the argument
is about,
right?
You say,
well,
you're angry at me.
Well,
why?
This is why I think you're angry at me.
And you say,
no,
this is why I think this event has
occurred.
And you're thinking about,
especially if we know each other well,
you're thinking about the
contextualization of that event across
our entire history and I'm doing the
same thing and I'm going to highlight
things that you're not going to
highlight and I'm going to draw causal
inferences that you're not going to
draw.
And for us just to get on the same page
about the memory's going to be very
difficult.
So the idea that in especially with
complex interactions with people that
you can somehow make a video recording
of the memory and actually capture what
happens is,
is very,
very,
it's,
it's not true.
You,
you can't,
I mean you might be able to extract out
certain objective facts,
but,
but generally if it's a dialogical
issue,
if it's a relationship issue,
it spans such a long period of time that
just cutting a slice of it out doesn't
constitute a reasonable record of a,
of what it means.
And that's what you're more concerned
with too.
Like when,
when you have an experience,
you're not under so much concerned about
what happened from an objective
perspective,
you're more concerned about what the
experience means.
And then you might ask,
well,
what does it mean to mean something?
And that was the question I was trying
to answer in that paper I had you read
right at the beginning of the class.
But one of the things that meaning means
is that it has implication for the way
you look at the world or the way you act
in the world.
And so if I tell you something
meaningful,
what that's going to mean is in the
future you're going to act slightly
differently or maybe radically
differently depending on how meaning it
meaningful it is.
But also that the way that you look at
the world has shifted.
And the way that you look at the world
is actually an unconscious.
It's actually an unconscious process.
I mean,
you don't know while you're looking at
the world,
how it is or why it is that you're
looking at the world in that way.
I mean because,
well first of all it would just be too
complicated and second you wouldn't be
able to concentrate on what was actually
going on.
So your attention,
for example,
is mediated by unconscious forces.
And you know that you know that
perfectly well.
And this is another 40 and observation.
You know,
if you're sitting down to study,
for example,
your conscious intent is to study,
but you know perfectly well that all
sorts of distraction fantasies are going
to enter the theater of your imagination
nonstop and annoyingly and there isn't
really a lot you can do about that
except maybe wait it out,
you know,
so you'll be sitting there reading and
your attention will flicker away.
You'll think about,
I dunno,
maybe you want to watch Jane the Virgin
on Netflix or something like that.
Or maybe it's time to have a peanut
butter sandwich or you should get the
dust bunnies from an out from underneath
the bed or it's time to go outside and
have a cigarette.
Or maybe it's time for a cup of,
or it's like all these subsystems in you
that would like something aren't very
happy just to sit there while you read
this thing that you're actually bored
by.
And so they pop up and try to take
control of your perceptions in your
actions nonstop.
Maybe you think,
well,
this is a stupid course anyways.
Why do I have to read this damn paper?
What am I doing in university?
And what's the point of life?
It's like you can really,
well,
you can really get going if you're
trying to avoid doing your homework and,
and then you might think,
well,
what is it in you that's trying to
avoid?
Because after all,
you took the damn course and you've told
yourself to sit down.
Why don't you listen well,
because you're,
you're a mess.
And that's basically why you haven't got
control over yourself at all.
And no more than I have control over
this laptop.
Okay.
So there's the memory function of,
of,
of the unconscious and there's the
distis dillutive function.
That's an interesting one.
The unconscious contains habits once
voluntary,
now automatized and dissociated elements
of the personality which may lead at
parasitic existence.
That's an interesting one.
I would relate that more to procedural
memory,
you know?
So what you've done is practice certain
habits,
whatever they might be,
let's call them bad habits.
And you'd like those things to get under
control,
but you can't.
So maybe when you're speaking,
for example,
you use like,
and you know,
and you say,
Om Malott and you've practiced that,
so you're really good at it and you'd
like to stop it,
but you don't get to because you've
built that little machine right into
your being,
right?
It's neurologically wired and it's not
under conscious control.
And anything you practice becomes that.
It becomes part of you.
And,
and that's another element of the
unconscious,
a different part.
And then there's a creative part,
which is that,
well,
you know,
you're sitting around and maybe you're
trying to write something,
or maybe you want to produce a piece of
art or a piece of music,
or maybe you're just laying in bed
dreaming and you have all these weird
ideas.
And especially in dreams,
it's like what?
Where do those things come from?
And even more strange,
one of the things that's really weird
about dreams and almost impossibly weird
is that you're an observer in the dream.
It's like a dream is something that
happens to you.
Well,
you're dreaming it theoretically.
So how is it that you can be an
observer?
It's almost like you're watching a video
game or a movie,
but you're producing it that at least in
principle,
although the psychoanalyst would say,
well,
no,
not exactly.
Your ego isn't producing it.
Your unconscious is producing.
It's a different thing.
And of course young would say,
well,
it's deeper than that.
The collective unconscious might be
producing it.
It's in some sense it isn't you exactly
or it isn't the you that you think of
when you think of you and that's the
eagle from the Freudian perspective,
the you that you identify with,
that's the ego and outside of that is
the unconscious,
the ID.
That's more of the place of impulses.
And you could think about those as the
biological subsystems that can derail
your thinking,
right?
And that govern things like hunger and
sex and aggression and your basic
instincts is another way of putting it.
And it's a reasonable way of thinking
about it because these are subsystems
that you share with with animals.
You share them.
Certainly with mammals,
you share most of them with reptiles,
you share a lot of them with amphibians
and even going all the way down to
crustaceans.
There's commonality for example in the
dominance hierarchy circuits.
And so these are very,
very old things.
And the idea that you're in control of
them is,
well you're not exactly in control of
them.
And I would say the less integrated you
are,
the less you're in control of them and
the more they're in control of you and
that can get really out of hand.
You know,
you can be like with people who have
obsessive compulsive disorder,
for example,
which which,
which is,
which seems to be,
I would say that dissoluted elements in
some sense of the unconscious,
the way that it's portrayed here,
poor people with obsessive compulsive
disorder,
they can spend half their time doing
things that they can't really control
and they have very strong impulses to do
the,
and it's very hard on them to block them
and holiday,
they'll almost panic if those things are
blocked.
And then you have people with two Rett
Syndrome,
you know,
that they'll be doing all sorts of weird
dances and spouting off obscenities and,
and,
and imitating people without being able
to control a 10 and sometimes a little
bit of antipsychotic medication can
dampen that down.
But it's as if there are these
autonomous semi spirits inside of them
that grip control over their behavior
and make them do things.
And you know,
you find that to some degree in your own
life because maybe you've become very
attracted to someone even maybe you
don't want to be attracted to the person
and then you find yourself,
you know,
texting them when you know perfectly
well that you should be going to bed and
you know,
you're,
you're in a grip of something and,
and you can't control it.
And that's all part of the unconscious
and all part of what Freud was studying,
the dynamic unconscious.
It's alive and it's a compass that the
mind is a composite of contradictory
drives.
Now the way Freud thought about this,
basically,
who has that with the ID and the ego and
the superego.
So if you think about the Ed as the
place where these contradictory drives
emerge.
So it sort of nature within the ego is
the thing that's sort of being pushed
back and forth by those contradictory
drives.
And the Superego is the thing that's on
top saying you better behave yourself,
you better behave yourself.
And so it's a different model than the
[inaudible] model because Piaget assumed
that what would happen is that as the
child,
and I liked the Piagetian model better,
I think,
I think in healthy development,
the Piagetian model is correct,
but an unhealthy development.
I think the Freudian model is correct
that instead of integrating,
say the aggressive and sexual drives for
the sake of argument into your
personality,
as you develop,
what happens is the superego just
represses them instead.
So they don't become a dynamic part of
you integrated into your ego.
They're just repressed.
You just don't manifest them.
And so that's how you be a good person
and you can be the victim of a very
harsh superego.
And that often happens if you've had a
particularly tyrannical parent,
one or both,
or maybe a tyrannical grandparent or
maybe your or your own inner tyrant and
you've picked up to radical voices
through your whole life and aggregated
them into this terrible judge that's
always watching you.
That's criticizing everything you do and
restricting you badly and really badly
and what you're allowed to not allowed
to do.
You see that with anorexic women,
well Ben could be anorexic too,
but it's much,
much less rare.
They have super egos that are just,
or it's one way of thinking about it,
that's just,
they're just deadly.
They just criticizing every bit of them.
Well,
right to the point they're really
criticizing the out of existence,
right,
is you have to be so perfect that the
perfection is not aligned with the
ability to live.
You don't get to eat,
you know,
and,
and people like that,
they look at their bodies,
they even look at their bodies
incorrectly,
like anorexic,
seem to be unable to see their bodies as
a whole that can only see their bodies
as parts.
And when you start seeing your body as
parts,
you're really in trouble because he
can't get a sense of actually what it
looks like and body perception is very,
very complicated.
Anyways,
Piaget thought about the ego as in some
senses,
the game that's played by all these
dynamic drives that shaped by the
broader community and so that could all
be integrated,
but Freud would say,
well look,
when that doesn't happen,
instead you're subject to the tyranny of
the superego and it just says you should
never be angry,
right?
You should never express yourself
sexually because if you do,
there's something wrong with you.
You're a bad person and you're a bad
person if you ever get aggressive or so,
and then people who are living like that
under those circumstances,
you know,
they get,
they,
well,
they're,
they're repressed is the right way to
think about it.
Now,
Freud was interested in the idea that
mental disorders could be caused for two
reasons.
One would be purely bodily,
like maybe a head injury or say in the
case of schizophrenia,
which is a good example of manic
depressive disorder,
we have reason to believe that there's
something physiological going on,
even though by identifying that has been
very difficult.
And it's probably because there isn't
one form of schizophrenia.
There's probably many pathways of brain
injury that lead to schizophrenia
symptoms.
And there's likely not one form of manic
depressive disorder either.
If you think of the form is having a
standard causal pathway,
we know that there are,
because we've done genetic studies on
people who have manic depressive
disorder in their family and you can
identify genes within a family that
seemed to be contributing to the
disorder.
But the problem is is that those genes
don't seem to be.
So then you'll take another family group
with manic depressive disorder and it'll
be a different genetic combination that
causes that.
So,
so part of the reason why it's difficult
to associate the,
even the more biological mental
disorders with,
with biology all the way down is because
they're so complex.
And then there are other forms of mental
disorder that don't seem to be
structured at all structural at all.
They seem to have more to do with,
well,
let's call it the psyche,
right?
And that it's more like the contents of
your thought have a problem rather than
the structures underlying your thought.
And of course that distinction is,
is difficult to make an a fine grained
way,
but you kind of get the point.
I mean just because there's an error in
your thinking doesn't mind really mean
that the underlying biology in some
sense has been compromised.
It's complicated because if the air is
bad enough,
then it can compromise the underlying
biology,
but whatever.
It's a conceptual distinction and part
of the conceptual distinction is,
is helpful if you're trying to think at
least in part about how you might cure
it because if you're thinking about a
brain disease,
then that
implies a different course of treatment,
at least in principle than it does.
If you're thinking about a psychological
disorder where you might think about
talking to someone,
for example,
in straightening out their thoughts or
helping them learn to behave in a
different way.
And it was really Freud who started to
think that he was the first person to
really pause it.
And this is pretty interesting to
directly pause it.
That dialogue or conversation or
speaking could be curative.
And that's another thing that people
don't like to give him credit for.
I mean,
there wouldn't be all of these helping
industries,
social,
social work and psychology and
biological psychiatry and so far is that
also involves communication and
counseling and all of these things.
Now that would have existed in all
likelihood if Freud wouldn't have made
the original hypothesis that there was
something about communication that could
be curative.
No Freud believed that
experiences that hadn't been now he
thought about experiences has repressed,
and this goes back to the videotape idea
of memory.
So the idea would be that you have a
record of everything that's happened to
you and the records actually accurate,
and then some of those things that
happened to you.
We're very,
very shocking to you are very hurtful or
very depressing or very threatening.
And so you've decided that you're,
those have become repressed.
You're not paying any attention to them.
Now he has a complex mechanism to
account for that.
And I actually think this is a place
where his theory went badly wrong
because you don't have a videotape
memory and it isn't obvious that the
memories that you have of traumatic
events are fully fledged and causally
appropriate,
but just not paid attention to.
It's more like they're murky and unclear
in and of themselves and they contain
too much.
And I don't think that people so much
repress as they do refuse to attend to
or are unable to attend to.
So it's more like a passive avoidance
than a passive avoidance of something
that needs to be explored and gone
through rather than,
it is something you know that you don't
want to look at that you are part of,
you has put away.
And I think that's a major weakness in
his theory and has led to a lot of
problems with the idea of repression per
se.
But anyways,
that was his idea that terrible things
have happened to you and you or some
part of you doesn't want to,
to,
to know about,
to know about.
And so they live this,
those repressed experiences live in
autonomous life of their own too.
And here's an example of a trivial
example of how that might work.
Imagine that you're at work and your
boss says something to you that disturbs
you.
Maybe it makes you question whether your
job is stable and so you're kind of
upset about that.
But it's a casual offhand comment and
you go back to work and you just sort of
forget that that even happened.
You know,
we baby cause you're attending to
something else,
but then you go home and you're just
crabby as as can possibly be and you go
home and one of the people there says
something a little annoying and you snap
at them.
It's like,
well that's analogous to what Freud
would call a complex,
right?
Is that this?
Cause you can imagine what's happened is
that the bosses words have brought up a
whole little subpersonality predicated
on doubt up to the surface.
And who knows how deep that would be.
Well,
what happens if I lose my job and if I
lose my job?
Well,
what sort of person am I exactly and
what about all these other times that
I've failed?
And then maybe you remember the other
times that you failed and what am I
going to do in the future?
And so it's this whole cluster of ideas
that surrounds that doubt and that's
been activated.
It's just a little part of you.
And then maybe you're not attending to
that because you're busy doing some
other work.
But when you go home,
something triggers it and it like it's
already there.
It's already get way more upset than you
should.
And that's,
that's what a complex is,
except in a much more complicated
manner.
Like a complex might be a whole series
of experiences that you've had that are
united by some emotion,
like threat that are,
haven't been transformed into a coherent
representation,
but that can rise out of the unconscious
and possess you.
If you guys,
many of you guys have been a depressed
at at least one point in your life.
You know,
it's actually very common for University
of Toronto Students,
especially in their first year.
It's about one in three if you,
if you have students,
the Beck depression inventory,
but one in three Touro,
University of Toronto students in our
research of have hit criteria for
hospitalization.
I mean the back is a little
oversensitive as far as I'm concerned,
but,
but you know what it's like when you're
depressed,
it's like it's,
it's,
it's a part of your personality sort of
subsumes the whole and depression quite
classically is,
well,
you can't think of anything good that
happened to you in the past and you
can't think of any reason why the
present is good for anything and you're
pretty damn hopeless about the future.
And so that's a complex as well.
And it's a complex that consists of
nothing but negative emotion and it
structures your memory and your
perception and your plans for the future
all at the same time.
Now,
Freud had a very lengthy list of ways
that people could be treacherous towards
experiences they had that they wanted to
repress.
And so he called them defense
mechanisms.
This is how you fool yourself into
believing that you don't have to take
into account a certain set of negative
experiences.
You know,
it's like,
well,
we'll go through the repression.
Okay,
well we talked about that denial well
that often denial's a very complicated
one.
Um,
okay.
See if I can come up with a good
example.
Okay.
What is a classic example for people who
have,
I think it's called Anosognosia,
I don't remember exactly.
It's neglect.
That's a less technical way of thinking
about,
so let's say you have a right parietal
damage from a stroke and you'll lose the
left side of your body,
so you can't move it anymore.
But a worse,
you don't know what's there and you
don't know that the left side of
anything is there anymore.
And God only knows how that happens.
But like you'll only eat half the food
on your plate,
only on the right hand side.
And if someone asked you to draw a
clock,
you'll cram all the numbers into the one
side.
And so you kind of lose the idea of
left.
And I think it's sort of like,
you know how when you're looking
forward,
there's nothing behind you.
You can't see anything back here.
It's not black.
It's not even God.
It's just simply not there at all.
And so if you could imagine that sort of
stretching around halfway at seems to be
something what neglect is like,
but anyways,
if you,
if you take someone with neglect
according to Robert Shaundra,
and then if you irrigate their ear with
cold water,
uh,
the,
the year on the opposite side,
then they'll kind of have a little
convulsion and then all of a sudden they
become aware of their missing left hand
side.
If you talk to them before you do the
irrigation,
you say,
well,
what's up with your left arm?
And they'll say,
well,
I,
I've,
my arthritis is bothering me and I don't
want to move it.
They come up with some something that
sounds akin to denial,
you know,
and then if you can snap them out of
that with that irrigation and they'll
have a catastrophic emotional response
logically enough to the loss of their
entire left side.
And Rama Shondra and reports that
lasting about 20 minutes and then
they'll snap out of it and go right back
into the denial.
And sometimes people deny things because
they can't update what's happened to
them is so overwhelming that they cannot
construct a new model.
They just rely on the old one.
And you see this,
well imagine first that you've just had
a tooth pulled and you know how many,
how long your tongue takes to remap the
inside of your mouth.
It's really hard to come up with a new
concept of you if something catastrophic
happens.
And so sometimes the denial is just that
something,
the thing that has happened is so
overwhelming that the person can't model
it.
But then maybe also they refuse to think
about it.
And you see this emerging in lots of
ways.
So for example,
if people develop diabetes for example,
they're often not very good at taking
their medication or regulating their
diet.
And you might say,
well,
they're denying the existence of their
illness.
And to some degree they're probably
doing that because who the hell wants to
think that they're diabetic?
But even worse than that,
it's like it's complicated to be
diabetic.
You're no longer the same person that
you were.
And so you have to learn a whole bunch
of new ways to be this new person,
what to eat,
when to eat,
how to check your blood.
You have to be careful whenever you go
out.
Neat.
Like there's,
there's a hundred new things a day that
you have to learn.
And so separating denial from inability
as a hard one,
but you can also understand that people
might deny no,
that's just not happening.
That's,
that's,
I'm not going to admit to that reaction
formation.
Oh,
that's one.
Maybe you hate your sister and maybe you
have your reasons,
but you shouldn't hate your sister.
So what you do is act as if you really,
really liked her.
That's an overcompensation.
So that's another form of,
of defense mechanism displacement.
My boss yells at me,
I yell at my husband,
my husband yells at the baby,
the baby bites the cat.
While they're not really dealing with
the problem,
which is the boss,
it's just pushed on down the road and
identification.
You're bullied.
And instead of coming to terms with the
fact that bullying occurs,
you start bullying other people.
Uh,
rationalization.
Well,
you know what that means already.
You know,
maybe you don't do your homework,
you're procrastinating.
I bet you can come up with 15
rationalizations,
no problem for why it's actually not
necessary for you to do your homework
right then intellectual ization.
Well Woody Allen's movies are about like
that.
He's got all these neurotic problems,
but he's smart.
And so he can come up with intelligent
reasons why he's so messed up,
even though he knows he's messed up and
it doesn't help sublimation.
Well that,
that was one of the things that Freud
thought characterized art.
So for example,
there's a lot of erotic content in art.
And so if you're having trouble
establishing a relationship or if you
want to have a relationship with many
people,
then maybe what you do is sculpt nudes
or paint them.
And then there's projection,
which is,
um,
I'm having an argument with you and I'm
unwilling to admit to my mo my dark
motivations and I'm very skeptical of
you.
And so I assume that your characterized
by all the dark motivations that I won't
admit to in myself.
So
now Freud also believed that it was
unconscious ideas that were at the core
of psychological conflicts and he
described those conflicts as
incomprehensible distress,
psychosomatic symptoms.
And so those would be the manifestation
of psychological,
of the manifestation of psychological
content in bodily form.
So that might be stress,
a stress related illness might be one
way of thinking about that.
I've had clients who had hysterical
epilepsy,
so that was quite interesting.
So that was a somatic of a psychological
problem back when Freud was practicing
hysteria was much more common.
And maybe that was partly cause
Victorian society was so centered on the
theater and so dramatic and people would
come in with like a paralyzed arm or
something like that,
that he could sort out with hypnosis.
And so they were manifesting their
psychological distress in bodily form,
often in a manner that was
representative of that psychological
conflict in some way.
Behavioral anomalies,
Hallucinations and delusions.
He thought that all of those could be
manifestations of inner internal
psychological conflict with their sets
of unconscious ideas.
So,
you know,
let's go back to the,
to the boss example.
Your boss says something nasty to you.
Come home,
someone says something a bit provoking
and you fly off the handle and then you
have an argument about what the hell is
up with you because they say,
well look what I said was,
you know this big,
and you reacted like this.
And you're going to say,
well,
no,
you're always annoying like that.
And which is kind of a denial thing.
And maybe the person doesn't let up and
they say,
no,
I really know that something's wrong.
And you do like six other things to keep
them the hell away from you.
And finally they're persistent enough.
So you break down crying and you say,
well,
I had this terrible day at work and you
didn't even really notice that you knew
that until the moment of the moment of
the tiers.
And you see that very frequently in
psychotherapy to,
if you're talking to people,
for example,
maybe they're relating a story about
their,
their marriage that collapsed badly and
they're talking and all of a sudden
they'll say something and they'll tear
up and then they'll continue.
And you can grab that and you say,
look,
you just said something.
I noticed that your eyes filled with
tears when you said that what was going
through your mind.
Now often they'll,
they,
unless you catch it quick,
they'll forget.
So they're talking and they'll have,
and the talking about the past is,
you know,
flashing off images,
stick memories,
and you'll say,
well that made you cry.
And,
and they,
they often don't like that because for
obvious reasons that something's come up
that they don't want to talk about.
And so you say,
well,
what was flashing through your mind?
And the personal tell you like quite a
lengthy little memory fantasy about a
sequence of events that you know is
still a hot button issue.
And that's another example of this
underlying complex,
you know,
and if you watch people,
you can watch people in normal
conversation,
this happens all the times.
Their eyes will move or they'll smile or
you can see as they're speaking that all
sorts of different ideas are flooding
through their head.
It's dreamlike in a sense too.
It's sort of as if the person is talking
and they're dreaming out the same time
there's this image laden set of memories
that's going on at the same time.
And that can be quite broad,
far broader than they could encapsulate
in the words.
And so you can catch that and if you're
really listening to someone,
really paying attention to them,
you can see when they're doubtful or
when they pause for a long time.
That's another one.
You know that something's come up that,
that that's occupying their mind and
interfering with the flow of
conversation.
Freud was very good at listening in that
manner.
Well that happens with jokes too.
You know,
like for example,
when I was showing you guys the lion
king stills the other day,
and I showed you that picture of Nella
laying on her back with that peculiar
expression on her face.
Everybody immediately laughed.
And the Freud would have considered that
an entry point into the unconscious
because there a reason you were laughing
about it.
It goes along with it well would have
gotten along with a sexual complex and
that situation.
And everybody recognizes it instantly
and they laugh about it.
And comedians are really good at that
because if they're good comedians,
they say what everyone's thinking.
But no one will say,
and it's a relief to everyone.
You know?
Uh,
what's his name?
Canadian comedian.
So always making racial jokes.
No,
no,
it's Canadian.
Yeah,
Russell.
Russell Peters.
I mean,
he's a great example of that.
You know,
he feels the whole stadium with people
of all different ethnicities and every
single one of them is dying to be
insulted because of their racial
background.
You know,
it's a relief to everyone.
So he had salts,
the herbs,
and then he insults the Jews and then he
insults the Christians.
And everybody's going,
Oh,
I'm so glad.
Finally someone said that,
you know,
so,
so he's speaking to part of their
unconscious and it's the part that's
actually uncomfortable with all of that
kind of discussion being repressed and
staying below the surface.
It's way too weighty for people.
So jokes express in playful language
would culture will not formally express.
So you know too that when the culture
starts going after the comedians that
things are not good.
So you should leave the damn comedians
alone because there are the people that
can tell the truth.
And if you start to get annoyed at them,
then that's not good.
So,
so Freud was also extraordinarily
interested in dreams.
Poor Freud who are just not going to be
able to cover them in enough detail.
Well,
how will we do this?
Cause I should tell you about the
dreams.
Freud wrote a book called the
interpretation of dreams.
And he,
he was the first person I would say,
who subjected dreams to a really
comprehensive analysis.
And he used them to investigate the
place of complexes in his
psychotherapeutic practice so his
clients would recount their dreams to
have.
Now he believed that dreams always
expressed an unconscious wish.
And that was tied into his theory of
repression.
And so for example,
if you are very,
very sexually repressed,
which was very common at the time,
then you'd have dreams with sexual
content that we're expressing the,
the uh,
expressing the undesirable fantasy
essentially.
And by analyzing the dream you could get
down to,
you could get down to what was being
repressed.
Now Freud believed that the dream more
or less tied itself in knots trying to
hide its content in some sense and young
believed instead that the dream was
actually trying to be as clear as it
could.
It just wasn't part of the,
let's call it the semantic memory
system.
It was,
it was more like a feeler out into the
unknown.
It was trying to represent things as
clearly as it could.
And so it's use of symbols and that sort
of thing wasn't so much to hide the
actual unpleasant content from the
dreamer,
but to express it in the only language
that the dream could use.
And so Freud,
of course,
also believed that some of that was
true.
All right,
well,
we're going to have to stop there.
So since it's two o'clock so we'll see
you on Tuesday.